we've got nothing to do with social
media we've not always being select but
because
make sure you focus on them I didn't say
that bro I said it I said it because
single parents will be gone on before
social media even on social media my
time that loves the single parents
around yeah
but it's got to start from somewhere and
that's where it started from there were
no single parents there were no single
parents in my mother's day they were
very rare yeah but you know the
difference is now the difference is
the difference is is that back in the
day when I got pregnant you didn't get a
house
you didn't get money and that was the
incentive back then so women didn't get
I knew a women that got pregnant just to
get somewhere there was an element of
shame in it as well there was an element
of shame that shame stopped after I had
my son because I was in the show but
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying after that it was a house hold on
hold on hold on hold on what I'm saying
now is that like bro like
oh yeah I forgot my bad
single mothers yeah it's not even
there's no Stigma to it now like they
single mothers get praised these days I
mean
I'm the mom and the dad like everyone
yeah like bro like it's not like before
there was a little limit of shame to it
like you know you're kind of bringing
down a reputation
the shame stopped in the late 80s and
the early 90s we're now in 2022. I don't
change what I said no what I'm trying to
say is that when she said about social
media and that that wasn't there that
was not the incentive there the
incentive back then was to get somewhere
to live I know women that back in the
day they went because as soon as you got
pregnant the government gave you a flat
right as soon as you got pregnant they
gave you money the more children you had
the more money you get it's only lately
that they've stopped giving you so much
money well that doesn't change that
doesn't change there was a there's been
I'm talking about this I'm talking about
the incentive nowadays if you're a
single parent and you've got
all right then let me twist let me turn
it in his head if you are a man
and you see a woman there and she's got
three kids from three different fathers
what the hell are you going there for
what are you going there for what are
you going there but exactly but you got
women out there with 12 children from
different fathers what are you guys
the government no I'm not talking about
the government because the government
ain't carrying you don't even let me
finish it because you ain't let me
finish the government the government I'm
the co-host
the government is not finishing because
let me finish the government right all
right I'm gonna let you think government
we've not got the people's dick so as
far as I'm concerned if you see a woman
out there and she's got a single parent
she's a single parent if she's if she's
divorced or if she's a widow a widow I
can understand but if you as a man have
respect for your dick if you see a woman
out there and she's got two children
from different fathers she's got free
she might be good at sex right that
might be your advert she might be good
at sex so you want to get in there you
want to like bang the box or whatever
you just call it nowadays and that's
your word I learned the other day from
the box but if she wants to do that what
the hell are you going out there for
leave the single parents alone I'm
talking about what I'm saying leave
those single parents alone because all
you're doing is making it worse leave
them if you see one or two people with
if you say a woman with she's got more
than two children for two different
fathers leave her let them go die a sad
lonely life don't add to it because
there's nothing there that they've got
to offer a man there's nothing that
they've got to offer a man so he's got
to work both ways because single parents
don't end up single parents without
sperm they need the sperm there they
were talking about why they become not
in the first place and we're talking
about how I was saying because I was
saying we were talking about incentives
back in that day it was like it wasn't
social media it was like for house and
money and whatever you always got
somewhere to live if you're a single
parent
and that's what they used to do if I got
pregnant right back in back in the day
if I got pregnant guaranteed within like
even before I had the child I'm gonna
get a flat working people like they
can't get a flat I'm gonna get a flat
but nowadays if you're if you know that
you see somebody with like two free kids
why are you going there
like yourself no one no one's advocating
for that though but they're doing it
because there's women out there with
five and six and seven for all different
fathers those those are thirsty guys
really those are guys looking for a
place to live that's not true living
with them the guy's not living with them
child support calculation and realize
from one Dad having six kids She's Not
Gonna Get Enough wherever whereas she
has six studs she's gonna get more I
guarantee you yeah you're not
insensitive most of those single parents
out there it's men like you use lot they
ain't got no kids
no I mean it's like you might have one
right a woman might come and see that
you ain't got none of it you know what
he's got none so to you your first child
is going to be important so I don't care
if I've got five guarantee that a lot of
them single parents out there they got
five first children
you got me they're set for life because
they got five first children and I know
lots of men that go out then they got
caught out because oh yeah she's on the
pill I keep but they turn around and you
know that if it's your first child
you're gonna do anything for that child
and that's how and they end up and
that's the incentive nowadays is that
you're gonna pay for your child if I
have a channel for you you're gonna pay
for your child you might sleep with me
and decide you know what I'm gonna I
might say I'm on the pill I'm gonna get
pregnant for you because your first
child so I know I'm getting money for
you for the next 21 years if I keep my
child in education I'm getting money
from you I can go and get money from him
and I can go get money from it that's
the incentive women and dinner yeah
hold on hold on hold on hold on can
everyone calm down all right all right
cool so as I'm saying yeah initially
what my what I was really getting at is
the initial that isn't initial the
initial decision or choice of guy yeah
because most girls even the ones that
don't have kids what the type of guys
that they they talk about that they're
after they want bad boys a guy that's
tall their ass good looking guys blah
blah blah they're not looking for a guy
that's going to be a father figure or
role model for potential children
they're just going over over superficial
things and that's what I was getting at
like I I agree with what you're saying
yes obviously the handouts the money the
house everything I've not bro like I
grew up around people like that oh yeah
I forgot I've got I've grew up around
people like that like do you get what
I'm saying like like you know free kids
three different that's like absolutely
but I'm saying we can get on to that but
what I was talking about initially was
the choices that women make in guys
because I don't think I don't think I
don't even think majority of women are
thinking oh yeah yeah I'm gonna have
three kids with free men Jesus Christ I
don't I don't think I'm not saying I'm
not saying that there ain't women that
do it but I'm saying I don't I don't I
don't necessarily think it's majority I
think a lot of times women will just
make portraits the first one will be
purchase then boom they found out all
right I get this
ah then maybe they have some some other
ratchet friends that tell them well you
know what if you have another one boom
you get this then that's what I think
happens I think it's more of that kind
of thing I don't think like 17 year old
girls on the whole there are exceptions
but I don't think on the whole they're
thinking oh let me just go and have like
a basketball team with different dads I
just don't think they're thinking that
they they have one
well like have you got any children no
but that's what I mean if I was these
new modern women that I see You'd Be My
prime target you would be my prime
target no I'm serious because you're
perfect you've got no children you're
handsome
can I say one thing when I was in
America what was so sad and scary is
that every time like I'm I met a new
girl whatever whatever it is on campus
outside campus dating apps oh how many
kids do you have and if you ain't got
nothing and then everyone say wow you
don't have no kids like bro like and
then the attraction goes up yeah like it
flies up like so I agree with what
you're saying like I'm just and bruh
it's two sides it's just like what was
talking about before there's two
elements to this like do you get what
I'm saying I think it's the poor choices
and then the incentives to make more
poor choices do you get what I'm saying
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible